I love this the hashtags found 40 Tiger
you are looking staffing can we see a
little twirl and the stress in my
ostrich probe I love it who makes this
dress big props to the birthday girl
happily married mama of three at forty
Melissa's thought down the forty pounds
she lost seven years ago weighing about
117 pounds thanks to Nutrisystem and
check this out melissa planned the
entire blue and white theme party
herself fifty gasps a three-tiered
chocolate vanilla cake a 113 acre
private estate and her husband Mark
Wilkerson was the surprise entertained
so now that we all officially feel old
since this girl is all grown up the
Clarissa explains it all star explains
why 40 is better than 20 a little bit of
wisdom a little bit of self confidence a
little bit of like I don't give a crap
kind of you know yes
Melissa learned to love herself just say
goodbye to the days of trying to figure
out her look we've got one of your first
in her no kidding I don't even have
makeup on I'm into computers at all look
at baby Melissa oh my gosh I'm missing a
tooth
high 40 Melissa knows she could leave
ex-boyfriends in the past
Ryan right now what they need a locked
lips yeah we work together and there was
like a moment where we live it I was in
a relationship with another boy I'm
sorry I stay true to that one but the
best thing is being grateful for the now
I heard someone say what if you woke up
tomorrow with the only things we were
grateful for today I was like that it's
so true like what if I'm not grateful
for the things I have right in front of
me then what is the rest of my life
about can't be always chasing it's
exhausting good point a great point we
also asked Melissa about the rumors that
there's going to be a Sabrina reunion
show she said not true not happening but
here's why listen the only comments will
be oh they all the Coles you know like
Oh everyone got a little did this one
got bad this one no why'd you change
your hair what you no no no no we all
got old too don't worry
you